needed it bad
bro
go right great shot great shot great
shot
this is even better
whoa yes sir oh there's the birdie
Charles that's it let's go that was
impressive right there
here we go
coming from The Mulch off of the tee
shot
well I like this taking the flight down
[Applause]
way to pick me up dog
this guy's looking for back-to-back
birdies
we are playing the third hole here in
the match back to Stephen Curry for just
a second because when you listen to him
and all he's doing in his house
Stephanie turning from the right my
home's still with a Chance
for birdie to win the hole
oh
now
oh I like it I like it I like it
is huge for the NBA guys
I'm sure you give me the right line good
team ball right there baby
oh
get in there let's go right that's crazy
I scraped it was it a birdie birds
so it's going to take an eagle to win
oh
[Applause]
yeah
we've seen that movie before that thing
just kept going huh it kept turning the
whole way hate to see it I can't believe
it
we might want to take our head off
we are through five and Shake Hands it
might be done oh yeah there's the lead
for Mahomes and Kelsey
[Music]
four bounce
[Applause]
that's ridiculous
some bears have been consumed out there
oh a couple of bears have been consumed
out here I just keep one kind of by this
by my side I actually got clay to get
one so I'm trying to try to get Steph
you know Steph's a little bit of a
challenge to get them to drink a beer
with us so we're gonna see what we get
oh
my God he smoked it back
don't get nervous
and there it is
Kansas City